ooh I'm actually glad this is a pre
movie logo for a second there I thought
it was about to accidentally watch after
Earth Comcast 47 seconds of logos might
amount to restraint in the current movie
climate but it's still simplest man Anka
Taylor joy didn't even look this lonely
in the which that's what happens when
you do a mercy inmate so Casey is that
weird outsider girl that no one is
friends with where is this high school
where the misunderstood outsider girl is
also the hottest one I believe you
wanted to invite everyone dad I can't
invite everyone in my art class except
for one person
wait her art class was the only target
for invites is Claire in third grade how
do you I think she gets detention a lot
and she yells at teachers sometimes
expositional parenting this abduction
takes place outside a pretty crowded
strip mall in broad daylight but nobody
notices the lengthy attack on the father
or the incapacitation of three teenagers
this is the one that he's so he's really
funny he does these weekly videos the
girl's final moments of freedom are
spent discovering the cinemasins YouTube
channel for the first time this mirror
is pointing severely downward and could
not be used for anything except building
suspense certainly not for driving if
Dennis shuts the trunk that would imply
that the confrontation with Claire's dad
has ended right so why does Casey see
nothing in the side mirror right after
the suspicious banging but sees the
spilled leftover is right after he shuts
the trunk did super clean freak Dennis
just kicked those to-go boxes over for
fun after he knocked out Claire's dad
also geez look at all those leftovers
didn't those girls eat anything no we're
going for suspense and the girls in the
back were absorbed in their phone but
dude was in the car for 30 seconds
before anyone says a fuckin word that is
entirely too many seconds
[Music]
okay several things here first off why
does he immediately take off the mask
after spraying the girls the knockout
juice was shot directly at Clara Marsha
sure but it's an airborne toxin and this
is a tightly closed sedan second Dennis
doesn't know anything about the KC in
the front seat but assume she'll be
chill enough to let him work through
some before he starts driving away third
I assume everything in the abducted
teenager handbook says you get the fuck
out of there immediately
rather than waste several seconds
contemplating the consciousness of the
abducted teens basically I'm saying this
teenage abduction in more ways than just
regular for this teenage abduction
goddammit you literally have your pinky
on a lock your hand on the handle and
he's not even looking at you green light
Claire asked KC a series of questions
that there is no way for her to know the
answer to this movie is really just an
excuse to showcase anya taylor joeys
ability to cry one tear at a time and
this elderly woman lives at the top of a
three-story walk-up
but isn't the slightest bit out of
breath when she walks in maybe she's a
superhero three students abductor the
father of one of the students woke up
dating King of Prussia he found the kids
and the car missing wait every time we
see Dennis used the sleep spray it takes
a long fucking time for the victim to
wake up takes at least 30 minutes to get
from King of Prussia to the Philadelphia
Zoo and the girls woke up after Dennis
threw them in the cell so dad was just
laid out in the middle of a crowded
parking lot until he woke up with no
help a new Philly was a rough city and
all but damn this is an orgy of evidence
that this is a therapist's office
Barcalounger for analysis checked cases
full of books that look like they've
been read got it weird gazelle looking
artifact to spur conversation sure I
guess the subject of Barry's email says
we need you but when dr. fletcher opens
the email the subject is re no subject I
for one am excited about the spin-off
film no subject the case of the missing
email subject dr. fletcher has the most
generic computer desktop in history with
no icons except desktop and recycle bin
i guess the only way to get the email is
to click on that nondescript trapezoid
on the bottom left
also this doctor apparently saves emails
that were sent over four years before
this movie came out also even though
some of these emails are clearly about
appointments and involve patients Barry
is the only name that has the last name
de-identified
if you open that door clear that's the
second locked door right but if she's
able to unlock this door just by turning
the lock knob with persistence who's to
say she can't do that again we should
drop a crazy-ass bomb on him like make
him watch The Last Airbender all the way
through also protagonists loudly planned
escape when the antagonist could easily
be on the other side of the door cliche
you're not one of us is clear saying
this because she and Marcia's
personalities are so indistinguishable
from each other that they might as well
be the same person
females are smarter than the male's but
you know that it's like killings the
stat is a good dad which guaran-damn-tee
is that he'll be dead before the end of
the movie maybe Casey blank stares so
much because she's living half her life
and expositional flashbacks boys make
too much noise yes they do I'll let you
know when I hear something that makes
sense Casey knows just what to do in
this situation because she went deer
hunting that time that's supposed to be
like like a tailored jacket but I'm
gonna hand print it with newspaper
headlines so this is Dennis who's posing
as Barry and he's only there to UMP you
skate the abduction from Dr Fletcher
because he knows Barry sent her an email
earlier but if this is Dennis why does
he not only have Barry's accent but he
also knows about fashion dennis is
supposed to be a completely different
personality my point is this movie's
explanation for how these personalities
interact does work well when I last
spoke to them they believed you were a
model employee so much so that they let
you live in an underground King bunker
on site does anybody care about us yes
the University of Paris has asked me to
do a lecture in fact people are
believing more because they're rejecting
the idea that you need evidence and
stuff also listen even if I ignore the
controversy about dissociative identity
disorder being real diagnoseable
pathology there is certainly very little
evidence of it being a dangerous
disorder except you know outside of a
universe created by the same dude that
did the happening I'm gonna take this
part of the movie with the biggest grain
of salt ever created I actually watched
your sketches Barry you're usually very
protective of them even though dr.
Fletcher is pretty sure Barry's not
Barry this prompts her to do nothing
until he emails her again they always
use your thumbs flick it flick it I'm
not entirely sure these two elderly
women aren't watching porn I don't know
how you work with those people what
people your patients that's pissed I
don't believe it yeah no offense
this was Barrett's exact response to
everyone who said no really split is
good man you would totally love it movie
expects me to believe that these three
girls
are all able to see through the crack in
the door at the same time even though
Marsha is looking at the back of
Claire's head and KC is crouching near
the center of the door also that they're
looking through the crack whines
Patricia's head obscured because it's
more interesting to reveal the Patricia
and Dennis are actually the same person
when he opens the door way this movie is
set up the only time the other
identities don't know what each other is
doing depends solely on the convenience
of the plot he's not allowed to touch
him not only is it rarely diagnosed it's
super rare for people with the ID to not
only have the means but time to play
dress up for every single fucking
personality well were they open this
time with the new evidence you submitted
video of a dog acting differently to one
of your patients at different time with
the over 600 patients our filing cabinet
suggested you'd think she'd be able to
muster up better evidence than that
recover them like they're super
naturally gifted like like they have
powers or something Porsche arguing we
have brain scans now di D patients have
changed their body chemistry with their
thoughts I'm guessing she didn't have
that evidence before the due date
forcing her to send the dog video
instead also it's telling that I would
much more easily accept being exposed to
gamma radiation or being bitten by a
super spider or being a bioengineer
raccoon as a more plausible origin for a
superhuman story than this Jesus even
for a doctor this is some unintelligible
handwriting and there's no chance
Fletcher would be able to get any
information from our own notes as a
nine-year-old Hedwig loves to play games
and one of his favorites is the pronoun
game the lady what are you blind
hey nobody for that SATs considering you
all know you live in the same person's
body and you know you're stuck inside
one person's head I stole a light from
mr. Dennis but he'll be back real soon
and you'll know and get angry and
they're aware of each other but mr.
Dennis he said that he followed those
two girls for four days so we're Marcia
and Clara together for four days or did
Dennis follow Claire and Patricia follow
Marcia wait also if he was stalking them
why did he pick the moment after the
birthday party when another girl and
Claire's dad was with them to finally
abduct them
come the fuck gone we just saw Hedwig in
full Hedwig costume walk away so it took
less than 13 seconds for him to change
mentally and Sartori into Denis the zoo
just happens to have human size duct
work to properly regulate the
temperature of this underground bunker
Twitter should have known she'd be
caught after hiding him what is clearly
Davy Jones locker
could you swim it's it's ruined it's
dirty because we have hot teenage girls
in our movie and we're gonna make the
most of it dammit so why didn't you put
them in different cells in the first
place there's obviously plenty of room
and a guy as fastidious as Dennis should
know that it's more difficult to deal
with three versus blond in an enclosed
area take off your skirt take off your
shirt dust
what's casually played as one of
Dennis's pervy character traits is
another cheap excuse for the filmmaker
to add a little disturbing sex appeal to
this movie the differences in the
identities can be dramatic so much so
that they feel the need to dress up
individually so movie goers can easily
distinguish them have these individuals
through their suffering unlocked the
potential of the brain no Jay what
health-conscious fast-food purveyor did
you originally solicit to buy these
chicken wings you've so lovingly
reheated in a minor suicidal gesture
goddamn em Knight was apparently
possessed by Aaron Sorkin for a minute
so look around 3:18 M night Shyamalan
continues his Hitchcockian desire to
have a cameo in all of his movies only
this time his character is hit cocky and
hacker who ving hooters
what are you object in us or is it
Patricia who's deciding things oh we can
make up all new personalities like the
ones that were casually mentioned
previously in the therapy office Glenda
LeBron Aloysius what are those assholes
up to I'm not gonna die
I mean I'm not gonna dock there sorry I
said we there coz there's no fucking way
you survive this it's good it's called a
freak a minute
dammit as much as I'm bagging on this
movie for having a ridiculous premise
James McAvoy's performance is awesome
I'll take a sin off for Dennis another
for Patricia and half a cent for Hedwig
because it's good acting but he still
kind of annoys me
I've had that Asian people's music aids
digestion citation needed of all the
potentially lethal or incapacitating
items in this kitchen Marcia goes with
the clunky folding chair which is a 100%
rate of ineptitude both in movies and
WWE events so the Beast is a legendary
figure in Kevin's mind but Hedwig says
he's done terrible things to people
before does he mean an act while
because Kevin Berry's been chillin at
this job for 10 years and Fletcher's
never met the Beast so when the that
happened yeah every one of us has to
wait in a chair and Harry he decides who
stands in the light if all the
personalities are sitting in chairs
waiting for their turn in the light then
what the fuck are they doing in the
meantime
they all have fidget spinners or
something to keep them occupied what
your may indeed be a doctor but the only
degree we're clearly shown here is a
masters so I'm calling into question her
qualifications also Tulane University's
obviously a made-up school anyway and I
guess that you emailed me in the middle
of the night due to garden-variety
issues and dr. flicker is the anti
Sherlock she's seen the news reports of
the girls that were taken on the same
day Barry emailed her she also knows
Dennis and Patricia support this
terrible piece character and that
they're likely at the wheel here and yet
she hasn't done jack to alert the police
or a colleague or anyone that could be
helpful in figuring out if there's a
link to the girls she's just been
checking off with him night while eating
hooters you and Patricia have never met
the Beast that's because he's not an
alter uh-huh
case closed nice job Karen let's wrap
this up and head down to Applebee's
while it's still a happy hour hang on
does every altar get their own room and
if so how efficient is that there were
23 of them and Barry has the light the
majority of the time so is he supposed
to clean up all their feed the gerbils
etc just dances equal parts hilarious
and terrifying making it essentially at
Drake music video tell them I still got
it Sarge here falls I would be angry at
this stupid dick on the other side of
the line that doesn't care about a
distress call but I'm more annoyed that
this asshole hasn't returned those
orange King headphones it's becoming
clear that Dennis's real super human
power is the ability to completely
change outfits this time in twenty one
King seconds this is a sentient creature
who represents the highest form of
humans evolution or Anya Taylor joy
always getting involved with God light
figures that demand personal sacrifice
Jesus try a comedy
he believes the time of ordinary
humanity is over wait are we talking
about the same beast that's one of the
x-men and the one that helped Charles
Xavier all those years when he looked a
lot like Dennis I was gonna ask for your
last shirt but what I want because it
needs to be slowly ripped off her if she
tries to escape later
the email received sound was what got
Fletcher over to look at the screen but
that's been going on for the last 15
minutes and she just heard it we're very
similar we are very similar you and I
cliche I'm a huge advocate for people
with mental health issues getting good
jobs in fact it's a great thing but even
people without severe psychiatric
illnesses should be looked at
suspiciously if they live underground in
a zoo especially if they work they're
brought about a woman in Germany who'd
been blind for ten years then three of
her identities develop sight optical
nerves regenerated because of her
beliefs discoveries like this dr.
Fletcher should just leave the
therapeutic field and dive straight into
the clergy what does that mean I don't
understand dr. Fletcher would be
excellent at cinemasins who are you
going to meet damn it they were about to
get through this entire vague
conversation without playing another
proton game we need to get out of these
roots Clare who was the first to try and
escape certain death fifty movie minutes
ago suddenly remembers she still needs
to escape certain death
oh good Casey finally found Kevin's hard
drive of exposition this air box says
unable to connect to the Internet even
though the Wi-Fi signal at the bottom
right shows full bars and there's no
indication that there is no internet
connection that this even sort of works
Fletcher mentioned earlier that the
Beast hypothetically lived in a train
yard since Kevin's dad was probably
killed by mr. glass and unbreakable but
why does Kevin need to use this
particular train damn orphan a beastie
other than providing ample time for the
girls to try to escape yeah when you see
a tough D ID case like this there's
always one asshole personality that has
to be addressed by his last name
looking at you mr. Prichard Dennis finds
a completely empty train car with the
lights ominously turned off for him to
unleash the Beast but but you know this
this can't be the first multiple
personality turns supernatural serial
cannibal case you've worked right
detective Dooley Fletcher has the
wherewithal to write Kevin's full name
down but isn't able to say it out loud
which has a much better shot of making
the captive girls aware of it more like
vanes McAvoy am i right the Beast loves
doctor Fletcher enough that he cuddles
her to death okay even if this is a
supernatural cannibal beast thing why
just eat a little bit of the midsection
and leave almost the entirety of
delicious Martian meat lying on the
floor
there have now been two savage murders
in Casey has heard screams from neither
of them Claire carpaccio
yeah it's creepy and everything but does
the Beast really need to be crawling on
the walls right now to get to Casey or
is he just showing the fuck off holy SH
for a guy that just eviscerated two
teenagers Kevin's hands are amazingly
blood free and killing Lecter said it
would be goddamn devastating for the
altars to hear Kevin's full name so if
it's so powerful why does only last less
than two minutes again oh girl Kevin is
asleep I doesn't sing that name work
after the first time because M night
says it doesn't work out at the first
time mother even though he could easily
kill her the Beast prefers to padme
Casey's shirt for future viewing let's
talk about the beasts plan he wants to
rid the world of the untouched but why
is this just a tiny twist on horror
movie he's always focused on killing the
fucking virgin that Tim showed the world
how powerful it can be powerful enough
to convince the movie studio to make a
sequel it's like that crazy guy in a
wheelchair that they put away 15 years
ago awesome apparently no other weird
murders have happened in metropolitan
Philadelphia over the last 15 years
leading this waitress to openly muse
about the one other link to a twisty
Shyamalan movie mr. glass so is this the
big M night Shyamalan twist this movie
shares a universe with unbreakable
considering the current trends in movies
I wouldn't consider the creation of a
cinematic universe a twist it's really
more of an expectation at this point
wait David still working a menial labor
job that requires at Dickey's work shirt
how is he not moved on a superhero
elsewhere that DC EU could have used his
ass for the last five years
someone need a hug like this why do you
act like you're not one of us you girls
get together have a few laughs
[Applause]
I've had that Asian people's music aids
digestion
[Music]
yes the Beast he's coming for you don't
mock me